thank you for joining us at 11 i'm brian
loftis and i'm denise valdez tonight for
the first time we are now hearing from
the waiter who was shot almost a dozen
times by a robbery suspect that shooting
happened at a chinatown restaurant back
in december he spoke to our own victoria
saha from his hospital bed as he
reflects now on that fateful night
it's been a long road to recovery for
chang yin wang he was finishing his
shift here at shanghai taste when he
realized someone had walked through the
back door and before he had any time to
react he was shot multiple times
through a translator by his hospital bed
chang yan wang describes to us the
moment he realized his life was on the
line don't worry
he didn't even leave me any reaction
time just put out a handgun and start
shooting at me wang says he wasn't able
to communicate with the robber in
english but understood he wanted money
what country
i turn around
trying to run through the front door and
i can feel that he starts shooting me i
heard bullets coming to
shooting at my back once outside a
security officer at shanghai plaza
called
911 the first officer
when he saw how many gunshot wounds i
have you can see that he was also
startled wang was shot a total of 11
times bullets hitting his head neck
hands and back he says he lost
consciousness in the ambulance ride and
woke up two days later at umc his first
thought
i'm still alive wang has been making
progress at pam rehabilitation hospital
but still has a long way to go before he
makes a complete recovery
who looks over me gave me a second
chance at life since the shooting
governor scissorlack has spoken up in
support of wang fundme has also raised
thousands of dollars for him
as for the suspect who shot wang his
name is rashawn gaston anderson he's
facing numerous charges including
attempted murder with a deadly weapon
reporting live tonight victoria saha
live local now